bismillah alhamdulillah can peace be
with you
welcome to the Deen show on hold on hold
on welcome to goddess TV and a version
of the deed show we are with share use
of Estes I'm guide of Stevie Dee show
live
we got a live studio audience and we're
going to be asking some tough questions
the time is short and we got to get with
it we got to my left should be to my
right but to my left over here we start
with Josh Evans Joshua Evans retires to
be and Sheikh Yusuf Estes and we begin
with peace Salam alaikum so we got some
questions now not to waste time you make
it straight into a serious business now
this is serious business on Adi sure on
Gaia's TV channel 99 channel 99 on world
TV channel and 19 on galaxy and also
channel 25 on galaxy we do it all these
mics sure yeah okay so now though we
have some questions from the do show
audience and also from our live audience
here now first we want to know the
people want to know their you guys you
know we have a lot of not yet Muslims
out their potential Muslims you know you
know that Islam is the fastest growing
way of life in the world today yet most
misunderstood so we want to clear many
of these misconceptions that on the
minds of the people so one thing that we
have if you want to know now you guys
have any affiliation with Osama Obama or
al-qaeda now this is for anybody anybody
can take the mic and go and that's it
and so you may need a Muslim the
majority of the world identify him as
being someone who has one outside of the
guidance of his land
maybe else want to add some to that
Joshua Evans use of Estes I'm happy okay
so we're going to continue on now
leading into the next question this
question is similar to the one we just
add that we just asked tell us if the
for the the question is asking if now
for says and I'm going to just kind of
add my own twist to it okay if because
it's time with the shoe bomber the
underwear bomber and the Time Square
bomber yeah so if the shoe bomber
because we have all these types of
bombers or the underwear bomber the
pajama bombers or the Times Square
bomber was to come to you for some
advice before one of these incidences
happened how would you talk to and
address the issue with this individual
to prevent something like this
they want to use violence to solve any
issue people agent in the big something
that they are Muslim the first thing I
discovered is that Boston mind
completely they have to be crazy
psychological they are attempting to do
another thing the very position which
they are professing to be even if they
say because there is not one single iota
of evidence from any authentic religion
where they're just teaching in a center
that allows us to use violence against
innocent people to vent our anger or
political agendas it is not possible to
expect the only type of aggression that
is allowed as families and events of
human life dignity and justice and this
is very clear the teachings of this
meant that to associate even the words
that they use in a terminology that he
used you know that you have to quote
will be born from Muslim divide the word
for Muslims - we don't waste it extract
the revenge and soulful rule is pretty
much an oxymoron because the word jihad
itself or any context of
on this episode of the Dean show on
guidance TV we Shaykh Yusuf Estes Matar
Sabri and Joshua Evans we know that you
Sheikh Yusuf Estes and and this I think
is directed to you and actually it can
pass on because all of you were former
Christians and now you have by your own
free choice you decided to be Muslims
and simply a Muslim is one who
surrenders submits to the one God so did
any of your family members the question
in there is asking disowned you because
of this decision that you made in your
lives and some of them were kind of nice
Christians to start with but I put a
pressure on their packing it up you know
follow Christianity here's the Bible
this is what we got to do and when they
come in the mind and start really
getting serious about it and then all of
a sudden I swing over because I'm it's
like oh man
so yeah initially but they delivered
home to love my father became a Muslim
my stepmother
the the first second she had a regular
Porsche guys and citizen had much better
relationship really with my family okay
Honda I've not had much opposition from
my family actually my nuclear family
early coming up was just my mother and
how she took her she had three months
before she returned or conditional
domicile coming to be life for me and
for her in fact when I lost without
called her back she died in Iran on the
oval juror so for me that was like
confirmation read affirmation this is in
fact the truth pretty much the same I
really didn't broadcast my name to my
family right away I just began to change
my not very good person when they saw
the change in the behavior when I became
a better son a better grandson person
individually and they were questioning
you know what has changed it UN is this
change real then I let them know that
that it was a snap that has changed me
and be a better person and even though
this day my father's really know and my
sister really the only people left
my immediate family my father today is
very proud that his son is around the
world telling people about a new person
a man tries to be good he's very very
proud of that he has no problem
whatsoever even though he himself has
not come
next question that's on the minds of the
people people want to know now our next
questioner is asking why do muslims say
that God didn't have a son and that
Jesus is not God
take it away deaf and the day of
judgment the mercy of Allah these are
the things that finally made me realize
there is no time to delay anymore I want
you to take martial heart of write down
the essence of spirituality is to become
more sincere to Allah so I want to play
tennis so it is very very scary
but it brings you back to reality there
is a life which is everlasting and you
have to make a conscious decision of
which a group of people do you want to
be people in heaven over the people of
hell
I am not afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid
why don't miss some say that God didn't
have a son and that Jesus is not God
take it away
it's very clear in the Quran that Allah
said so this isn't an option for Muslim
if you understand what corrado means we
understand it is the actual speaks of
Almighty God in Arabic language and in
and he said under condition about it
right now means both say o Allah I've
had these a lot any uniquely one okay
it just doesn't have this kind of one by
the way we say one would mean one in our
make you say what head but when you say
I had this is meaning a word that there
isn't going to be a to coming after it
oh no who son this means Allah is
totally independent of his creation but
the creation needs him all through
eternity now listen here lamb now Lana
is kind of like no way Jose okay laughs
yummy for sure he is not the father of
anybody well then you like it he's not
the son of anybody when I grew up with
la boum poof one time and he's not like
anything that you could ever imagine
nothing in creation is not in creation
he's not D creation like Hindus for me
or some of the others he is totally
independent of this creation and then
again it says let you know who won uh he
is unique so honey it's pretty clear why
we would say that because I like I said
he doesn't have a son and if it's not a
son and God is a man and the son is a
man that's a chauvinistic
where's the ladies in them and babies
don't come from men though they know
they come ladies
so Issei is from when we looked at the
Bible we understand that the words
spoken about Jesus or less heaven spoke
about Jesus sometimes regarded as they
read that verse with read that is
printed in the New Testament are to be
his words you never find the Prophet
Jesus feet behind ever refer to himself
as the Son of God he always refers to
himself as the Son of Man as the son of
man then the term sons of God were found
throughout the Bible in many many places
so Jesus was the only one called head
but even in the Old Testament some of
the prophets were called something but
this was a metaphorical expression it
didn't mean that God physically sired a
son through the agency of a female but
how many left so we referred to Jesus as
he saw himself as the Son of Man and we
worship the one whom he worship for me
all the nicho the top ten reasons why
Jesus cannot be God and God cannot be a
man but realistically is because there
is no religious scripture anywhere that
makes this claim from any prophet of God
this is coming from other sources and
very clearly when we look at the
teachings of God throughout the entire
the Old Testament he never teaches this
theory God is one unique when we read
what is it called the famous statement
that is in the Old Testament which is
known only Jewish
well resides thinking which that every
Sabbath here o Israel the Lord your God
is one in Deuteronomy yes and it's in
and this is as you describe the oneness
that is described in the Hebrew language
is very similar to the Arabic language
and it's very clear that this is the
exact same teacher that Jesus himself
for it means when they asked him what
was the greatest commandment what are
you saying he said well I'll tell you
the first command is to hero either the
Lord your God is one the Lord your God
is one and that oneness that he referred
to is very very clear without knowing
the verse by verse by verse by first we
just have to understand this oneness
that you were speaking about it is very
similar to what he said the word in the
in the language we have a number for one
rights what is the what is being worked
for the number one none of it one
correct yes audience Ronnie if I take
walking and I had it to like it
I get his name I get to but the word in
the Hebrew language is synonymous to the
word in Arabic language that Jesus
himself used in the anime
he said that hero either the Lord your
God is one in reference to the exact
same word I had none if you take a head
which symbolizes a unique one is which
the chair users call or not and you
think I haven't you addict I haven't you
get you can you can't get one without
the possibility of addition or
subtraction it is a one all on by itself
and this is who God thought that he was
throughout the entirety of the Old
Testament and this to Jesus talk God was
so to say that Jesus taught him
something God goes in contradiction to
the very teachings he came to professor
very teachers he professed about God and
there's one more things like this by the
way if you want more clarification
there's a website we have called nine
one one Bible nine one one Bible calm
and it says son of who read article is
that real clear moving on to the next
question with our wonderful guests a
wonderful panel here now we're here to
university broadcasting live and and I
think many can relate to this now okay
basically paraphrasing the question the
questioner is asking you know they can
understand he can or she can understand
the the the simple teachings of Islam
pure monotheism worshiping the one
creator and not his creation they can
understand the concept of accountability
paradise hellfire reward if you do the
good things that guy's telling you
but now the individual is saying you
know many people go to college for the
experience now if I accept Islam if I
become a Muslim just like Jesus was a
Muslim Moses Abraham there are Muslims
they submitted to gratis for the Muslim
is so if I accept Islam and I become a
Muslim do I have to give up my
collection of collection of VIP
nightclub nightclub cards you know and
the weekend from time with the boys and
the partying you know do I have to give
this up
how would you guys answer this
during his lecture he explained with
some means yes sir
you explained with me that is that means
that it's not means uh what is your
sense render submission of obedience
sincerity and peace so you submitting
yourself to the creator each and every
single day you know be studying with
sincerity so that you can obtain peace
in this life and in the next the very
definition of Islam itself means that
they're going to have to be some things
that are gonna have to be weeded out
things which are cut in my life that are
contrary and this goes for Muslims this
is not just you know just new Muslim
just goes for all the times they're
going to be things in our life we have
to weed out whatever we find that our
life that is contrary to this meaning is
going to have to be removed because as
he stated to be a Muslim is an action
word it is a verb it means one who does
Islam one who does submit themselves to
their creator each and every single day
with surrender and obedience and
sincerity in order to attain peace so if
I'm doing something contrary to that
then I have some problems go on one of
my life and those things are going to
have to be removed because if not you're
gonna find conflict and as Jesus peace
be upon him is all that we have said in
the Bible that one heart cannot serve
two masters one heart cannot serve two
masters for it will either fall in love
with one and despise the other
or it couldn't delay both you never know
but it cannot have love and servitude
and obedience a surrendering and peace
to two different country I noticed one
of these
one is going to lead itself out unless
you lead it out yourself and usually
what's going to happen is the negative
is wonderful power just because of the
very structure of human beings it's
going to happen that way so we're gonna
have to lead those things out yes but
that's in an attempt to do a snap and
BMC in the science or many is recognized
as the only one who has the right to
make lawful and unlawful and the most
most of the things that we do are those
things that Alliance made lawful there
are more things that are permissible and
lawful than they are that are not
permissible so the things that we used
to do before we came to this lab we have
come to know that those things that are
very hospitalized and will only bring us
destruction so what is it to give up
drinking alcohol or using drugs or
chasing women you see or going out to
the parties that's nothing compared to
the reward of peace in this life and
guidance and the greatest reward to come
into paradise I just wanted to just add
something confirming what you said I
just came back that you know from Saudi
Arabia one of the shows that we're
producing from them we're not doing it
yet we need to get some more technicians
to help us finish it but it is called
love at the racetrack that's how the
Rakata
lit up at the racetrack and we're
talking about racing horses now how can
you imagine as anything the movies life
one of the first things you observe when
you get there there's no gambling
whatsoever allowed you will be a
city example another thing is there's no
alcohol about at all anywhere in the
kingdom so that's a whole different
picture in it
but what we really wanted to focus on
well it was also the no advertising all
of the signs that you saw going on there
just said Allah Akbar Allah under that
grace god things like this but when they
were putting the horses into the shoes
our friend who's a convert himself David
Rogers and it was beautiful because he
would coax the horses into the shoes
with words and guests inspired those
horses and because it horse whispering
now this is an old technique used by
people that work with animals that don't
want to hurt them our other side they
just wanted an animal to cooperate we
actually caught on camera some of these
brothers who don't know he's technique
trying to butch a horse in there shoving
it tugging at it with a robot and trying
to drag it in the chute it wouldn't go
in the meantime David is sitting on top
of his horse talking to another horse
that they're trying to load and he was
skittish but you want input later when
we got a chance to get to the stables
and properly in front of the horses he
said all these sources used to be afraid
the skinny who came up they would love
the death side of the stall he said
gonna be stand there while we're talking
too much what happened so what we're
doing what we're doing right now
three years old the horse would come up
and push the neck my head it is yeah 1
billion is sort of heavy you know what I
mean want to be on TV I guess I don't
know but he said the reason is horses
goodness love the horse does what he
does a love he wants to please you he
wants so much to please you now I
understand that the cactus same way he
just will over right in front of you
you're trying to walk the road right
there
extracted and they put his head up
against you the cat people coming at me
God loves you why do these animals do
what they do and this was the whole
point that the negative drivers wanted
to make on the show because they really
will do what they're supposed to do if
they truly love you and I love said
about that in a grande Cooley Cooper to
people in the lobby and you know you
become aa well get a vertical no no
become pull out of the park if you
really love a lot if you really no
problem because then and maybe then a
lot of looking and he will forgive your
sins he is the forgiver he isn't a
street life who have tried so you know
well and live that life of making just
ourselves have you trying to fill
ourselves with this money like this
pleasures come in the morning you're
gonna bring anything you can think of
imaginable
I know that Eddie is not to mention home
on this life and one thing that was that
all young people I didn't know that it's
this like it entices you let us be that
I guess you could say that the spokesman
of the antithesis of that if that's not
going to get you idiot you know the only
thing that we were trying to do and I
know I personally was trying to do was
trying to put a bandaid on the damage
that I knew was inside of me you know
with these without all with the
authority we know that I was trying to
bandage the damage that was inside of me
that was like I had a big hole that I
was trying to fill with these things but
know for sure they're trying to feel
that this is one of my first scholars
that opportunity literally shake you
suppose very well decide you need used
to tell me that for a man or I wanted to
try to feel that hole inside of
themselves their desires were the things
of this world you might as well go to
huge and try to fill the ocean of a
sense because it is an impossibility to
do that you cannot feel your desires
is like trying to throw water it's Santa
to the ocean can you fill it
honey cannons and then he wanted the
statement of the bottom piece of money
that the only thing of this morning that
will fulfill the desires of the human
being is the dust of the grain that's
the only time we'll be satisfied is when
we have put inside that great so don't
go chasing a life that is going to bring
you nothing but in a full circle back to
understanding in your life you're
sitting right here and right now
continuing on here with our wonderful
panel of guests on the Deshawn qaeda's
TV yeah not so classic go to my room
lock the door go straight and class
thank God you know me better than myself
show me the right way and I will not
look I will leave everything behind a
lot of that grater and grate everything
keeps encouraging to people
and we would go on to the next question
we got several more questions but we got
so little time so we're gonna try to get
through these quickly the next question
are you ready
asking the tough questions here on the
Dean show is Sheikh Yusuf Estes guide as
TV Christians feel now okay
they feel Christ through the Holy Spirit
Christians feel quite through the Holy
Spirit
what internal proof does Islam offer
that's the question
talk to me let me let's go with Tahir
then we'll go to Yusuf and then we'll go
to but from the Islamic perspective this
is referring to the angel of revelation
gibreel or gave me the wrong scriptures
to the fathers who secrets of jesus
receiving the gospel
also received over it running receives
the scrolls of the sort and the Bahaman
someone or some other piece of quality
if you see goron so we have an
understanding that the Xperia loneliness
is not a personal experience what it is
one that only comes to the profits
investors from Almighty Allah has chosen
well I'm just going to ask the question
they asked how to find internal evidence
for the quality system there's a very
beautiful person for honor that pretty
much sums it up for me where Allah the
Almighty Creator says the one that in
remembrance of him do hearts find rest
in phantoms and this is the reality and
I can tell you that coming out of
Christianity that even those emotional
highs but that is something that needs
to be refurbished to replenish those it
does very quickly but there's something
different about sin that can only be
experienced the only the experience is
that contentment that refined and
remembering the one two three or four
things is the way he wants to be
remembered with that purest and that
oneness so internally the evidence is
only for is only in eyes of the
it's not something that I can cut out
and someone else the external evidences
that God gives us is part of that
internal evidence for us to have peace
in our lives and in the remembrance of
God do hearts find that rest and content
and the songs have stated at the Regal
welcome is life isn't good and that's
one thing for sure that I know without
trying to balance on religion that the
Holy Spirit doesn't give you it might
give you that feeling when it's good
when things are good you might have that
enjoyment of the Holy Ghost but when
it's bad do you have that thing of
contentment with whatever God is given
that's something that I put in I have
contentment and rest because
I spent a lot of years in business and
marketing alliance and what I remember
about people being filled with the
spirit when you get somebody on stage
and he really out there shouting telling
you how this exciting experience and how
you doin how what I am now I want to
share this one I have with you here's
what I have for you today we were all
excited and the people I will not do it
with that spirit of what he was talking
about but it wasn't even Christianity
wasn't even limited that was sellin
Herbalife you know by halfway but in but
this is here's the truth cause you asked
for proving it some life does not know
Arabic language at all yet when they
hear the words of the Quran in the
Arabic language and they start crying
what is that what is that because when I
first wanted the Quran decided how it
was trying to convert a Muslim to be
pushed yet every time he would recite I
feel like Oh besides singing and slower
oh that's nice I didn't know these would
act the exact words recited to 100 by
the Holy Spirit
the angel Gabriel one of the most
powerful of all and I used it when I was
doing
chapter 1 it's the verse in surah bakra
chapter 2 verse stupid [ __ ] I recited
this one time and right next to where we
were holding our services some
Christians were over there being filled
with every published okay here we were
trying to talk with wouldn't even hear
ourselves the breath said you know they
do that every time we're trying to have
service I said though said then I think
we mice together
oh he initiated on your genes in a tube
while at home who this summer what you
about Helen muddiness boohoo livability
ha ha ha
English Wauseon courtesy use some whole
lot the one well that's the whole love
people love me remember beats those last
words these guys became totally silent
and never made another piece well we had
our services the meaning of those were
saying the cypresses nothing in English
so we'll bring it I know I've tried many
times I'll try again tonight and then
for those who fell upon her they don't
know about Islam Allah says here that
he's a walk but one disciple there is
nothing worth University the ever living
the self-subsisting he does he get tired
he doesn't sleep then he asks the
question but first he tells you that he
is the owner of all of the universe
everything in it heavens and earth bless
him now comes a rhetorical question who
is there
he's asking who is there in the guns
between me and my grace given permission
to do so there's no intercession in his
life except that Allah gave me
permission to do such then he tells you
that it's a law that has all the
knowledge of everything and you don't
have any knowledge said he his kursi
extends all the universe and he feels no
fatigue and taking you and he is mighty
and majestic thank you show Yousef and
we have a couple more question before
this live filming of the Disha on
guidance TV which they use of estimate
on Sabri Sheikh metalia and Joshua Evans
hope everybody's enjoying this
episode and we're going to get into the
next question now the question is asking
pete king peter king just had some
hearings about the yes he said three
times is lab but the terrorism all
probably extremely extremism is
destroyed extremism be destroyed it
would be this three times so sadly
encourages imbalance and moderately life
and it forbids us to to go to extremes
too far to the left too far away now
everything we witnessed by eating and
see to know that the Senate committee
envisioned
we held another hearing about two weeks
later we'll do the flip side missionary
is Harry promoting your sign for me so
you know above themselves that we have
to ask the question why has there not
been a plethora of Muslim extremists
doing crazy things you know as an
outcome of this discrimination see and
actually was saying very much SAIC to
reiterate this is he was saying that
there's not enough Muslims saying thing
but there's not enough from speaking out
about it and this rapidly initiate you
said that this very much in turn
according said it's turns out being
pretty much not absolutely centered on
people anyway so very weak of these type
of things we just kind of say that there
is dumb truth he had to say what he had
to say
right to say what they want to say
that's a constitutional right before in
plus let's say we had the same when it
comes to judging the way to what he has
to say that's that that happens to be
talking she shop she not one of the most
important things about being a Muslim is
the truth even though it says in the
larger 17 verse 81 the truth the hot
will come and it would destroy the
bottom
verily the truth will destroy the bottle
of the body will be destroyed by the
street by the his falsehood hot and but
this is the subject was started with
tonight by the way were talking about
truth and we and I was listening to
usually just talking about the subject
that when the truth is there the
alternate cannot exist but when there is
no truth then there's what the bunny
says except off foot and we will go back
to what we said on my own it's our
responsibility brothers and sisters and
I'm saying are the sisters in humanity
even if you're not Muslim you still have
the responsibility to many much were
goodnight this is not something you can
ignore this possibly just one way mom
didn't say well I still want to believe
this or that well the truth is here is
it one ball list and as I've
responsibility to say the truth now I'm
going to contradict you I'm going to
contradict you in a little bit of way
because I have to say the truth and one
of them are maybe 4,000 questions in the
United States in 99.9% of all of those
are bringing out some of the best of the
youth that we have some of the great
view that we have here working on us
tonight
still that's not always the case there
are some Muslims when we misguided and
when some really stupid things and I
know that to be in fact because there's
a must a month across the street from my
house two houses down
in other words walk out to live the
street walk for 60 seconds and you're
inside the must that's it you know where
it is you guys know right it was in that
exact old house we're fine but our own
brothers in Islam conspired and drew up
plans to sneak off get on an airplane
and fly the Pakistan and jump off the
plane and declared jihad and then I went
to jail immediately it was that stupid
well first of all time honey you know if
you went to Pakistan
maybe they love it it's about these boys
hit that none of us knew not one of us
that wants to do them I found out when I
put someone all the time I found out
when I came back buddy I hate to stand
on my porch and then ask me what we
would do to these guys is what nice when
they started tell me what's going on and
I'm like oh my god I hear something
about some boys with Rebecca said she
got her streak reals
whoa so we don't know what you're
teaching lesson
Hajis nothin I'm not all the time I'm
out here and then they brought home
movies look what the FBI said to me they
said how you hold on the world but you
can't go across the street I said what
do you mean this and we've seen yourself
we know who you are and the mentioned
view by the one they sell to each other
what do you think I'm taking your head
but if you let them any now they said we
know you guys we know what you're about
and you know we want you to teach this
the realest line
I'm shocked they were telling me they
literally said we'll cross the street
and start teaching these guys how do you
let this happen
thinking about if the United States FBI
is how you mean sacred to accrete I'm
wondering about regenerate thing that no
mayo or this may help all of us well we
certainly glad you took the opportunity
to comment it was created courage we
commend you for the courage come out to
be with us we have a question for you
are you ready to obey the one that along
with our partners on disturbs you if you
believe in God you would you consider
this as a way of life for you to become
Maggie said yes he said yes
who else would like to complain that
they want to believe in the one guy that
serve Him
anybody else raise your raise your hand
no Maggie raise our hand to us who else
Yeah right
masha'Allah what's your name
Oscar Oscar I like this thing
I saw our Sesame Street it's only
clothing on there right anyway it's nice
to have you guys with us tonight we do
commend you and we make we don't need to
clap for you want to use something
better than this clapping it noise how
many of you Muslims if I say a prayer in
Arabic they'll say on me okay I don't
know yeah well Dina so I was 13 and Dina
cerrado was latina and he's put that in
English our Lord guides to the straight
path that is the straight that whoever
says this deep in their heart a love
about them and that's what it's all
about
you started a piece with every piece
piece blew up to everybody that attended
and peace be unto you my guests assalamu
alaikum
you